you know there's such affection for
these characters and it all begins with
you guys and so I want to take a moment
to illustrate how special you guys are
and I was hoping you could go back in
time I'm going to start with you Robert
look to your left and I want you to I
mean we're going to go down the row and
I want you to try to recall your first
impression of the actors to your left so
you're gonna start do first and for
first impression if you can recall start
with that you get to look at Sarah your
first ferris depression this is the
easiest job in the world I just remember
I just remember thinking this is one of
the greatest actors have ever worked
with Sarah and and to watch her in these
scenes she has this great ability to not
look you in the eye until you really
need to be looked in the eye and then
there's a lot of TV actors just UX I'm
just like and then to realize like this
time around to realize that I'm going to
be acting with her and some really juicy
scenes are pretty amazing Dominic
Dominic just loved to pick on me at the
beginning I used to come home and and
I'd be all bruised up and I'd say well
that's just par for the course TV I got
thrown on the hood of a car and but we
got through and my one of my favorite
moments with what worth was towards the
end of the it wasn't the first
impression
although I have to say the first
impression was he took really good care
of me
and he included me in the company
because I wasn't in the pilot I was in
the next episode and towards the end of
the summer in the first season we were
having back in the days when most of us
smoked we stood against the wall we were
having a cigarette and I turned to
Wentworth and I said this is pretty good
isn't it
life is pretty good it finally got cool
at the end of the day we were leaning up
against the wall in the evening those
are great great memories they'll never
go away sure you go now impressions of
these guys first impression first you
know I don't it was a long time ago haha
I mean we were babies I remember uh I
came to set to watch them film before I
started and it was Chicago and it was
Joliet it was snowing like crazy and
super cold and
it worth and I went for dinner try and
get to know each other a bit and we were
walking back through Joliet and there
was a empty building that had been used
as a campaign headquarters and it was
littered with these signs for some
candidate named Barack Obama who was
running for the the Senate in Chicago we
turn to each other and we're like well
the name like that that guy will never
get anywhere like it was just it was
like super idiotic conversations that
four years later made us both into
idiots
um I think you I think Dom might have
growled at me but you were really nice
later like that's like a first
impression which is like hey I'm Sarah
oh I don't Robert and I didn't work
together in the first season and so most
of my first impressions with you were
watching your work as the episodes came
out and I was just floored I was just
floored by what you did I thought was
really brave Dominic how about you first
impressions of Rob were um unique really
odd I think he's one of the first actors
that I can't really worked with that um
was really into the method you know um
he doesn't press by his glickman to to
his craft
Sarah was man this woman stuff is [ __ ]
so yeah let you know who struck and
Wentworth very private very just a
gentleman someone that I had never I
mean like grew up in a very kind of
rough area in Australia my friends were
all gone a law and here was a guy that
was the complete opposite of all of us
and he was just very polite very gentle
very sincere and the most beautiful
looking man I've ever seen in my life
right
and I was like hang on I thought I was
the stud on the show that's just not
gonna happen
he'll Wentworth I think my first
impression of Robert was one of ah an
appreciation from the very first scene
we had together I was impressed with
this man's boldness and his choices and
I thought this is good news because a
show like Prison Break lives and dies by
the quality of its villains and the man
had quality in spades
Sarah I think our first scene together
was probably in the infirmary I don't
really recall it was a long time ago but
I remember appreciating very much the
quality of her work and also the fact
that for a moment I wasn't working with
dudes it's such a testosterone fueled
show so to have those scenes be what
they were it was a change of pace and a
respite and a refuge sometimes and
Dominic I met at I think it was a
chemistry test at Fox and I thought well
we both have shaved head so I could sell
that brother thing I knew we were in
what are your plans for your body will
we see the same tattoos that Michael has
a fresh set of tattoos and they are
central to the plot but they don't work
quite the same way they did the first
time around
oh my question is um what brought up the
revival of Prison Break the reason I ask
is because at the end of the last season
the characters fates
had concluded um you were dead and you
know we've all been guys we'd hurry so
um yeah what brought you guys together
again for such an amazing revival show
um I was working when with uh wanted
someone to work with him on the flash
and he basically he got my he got my job
on the flash that the producers were
looking for someone that was a hothead
who was aggressive it was a
unpredictable type and force of nature
shutting they said right and Wentworth
civil was anyone going for that that's
dumb so that's how that happened then we
can we got on set and it was just like
we hadn't been apart for all these years
and we started talking about prison
break and we started you know warming to
the idea of why don't we just revisit it
maybe and we went to the producers that
was dawn and she said yes and the
process is very quick after that and I
will say if it wasn't about the green
light essentially came from Wentworth
next question hi this is for Michael
this is Kate from San Diego and I was
hoping to see or to know how long did it
take for them to put all those tattoos
on your back in the original series in
the original series I had a full body
tattoo front back arms it took about two
hours to apply an hour to take off but
it was only once an episode this time
around there were fewer tattoos it only
took a half hour but it was every day
next question hi my name is Jillian and
I'm from Texas my question is after
working together for so many years what
are the craziest memories you have from
being on set all awesome good can I sit
and say that can't say that can I can I
answer that in a sort of a roundabout
way one of the one of the coolest things
about seeing these guys this time around
was it was it wasn't I never felt there
was a moment of going hey how are you
how you been all these years it wasn't
nostalgia it was a bunch of actors
telling a story right now and how the
hell we going to do it to keep it fresh
that was so exciting at the same time
what it was also great is
any actor you work with in this business
that's a star or famous before prison
break I'd go I don't know how to relate
to those people it's pretty great that
they're you know known but this bonded
all of us in a similar kind of
experience which was kind of amazing to
look at each other and go is it the same
for you man can you go anywhere in the
world without knowing who you are and
we'd all say nope everybody knows this
and that's a beautiful little safety net
for all of us to go yeah I hear you man
it's the same way it's a beautiful thing
it's also a curse because we gave up our
anonymity by playing these characters so
when I remember we had a scene in the
infirmary
I know that's gonna really narrow it
down um you'd been burned and you were
facedown and you were waking up and
looking at me and I remember I had to
say my line was I had to perform a
procedure to this day I can't say it
without laughing I don't know why um
we'd been in that infirmary for a long
time and their cameras on my face and
wentworths back of his head is to the
camera and he would just kind of go I'm
like open one eye and try and watch me
say it I mean it was probably 25 takes
before I got it right um that was yeah I
don't for some reason that's a moment
that sticks with me wherever it's just
watching me try and not make an ass of
myself you know Roberts point that he
just made it it's a good place to jump
off how can you talk about the delicacy
of tackling this I mean it is called
Prison Break so you have to obviously
incorporate that but I mean at what
point does he become rehabilitated I
mean what what was that talk about the
challenges of figuring out the next
chapter writing this next chapter that
was yeah okay um I had a great
conversation with Paul sheering in early
January and the my knee-jerk reaction to
the idea of this coming back which was
you know had begun these two down here
was please God make it different please
don't just give the audience what we've
seen before and these
actors and these characters have changed
over six years and I got a promise from
all of them that that was indeed going
to be the case that this was going to
give we were going to give you what you
loved and knew from before but we were
gonna go in a much deeper place more
mature more brazen and simpler I think
and for teddy I think that the catharsis
and the epiphanies that he's gone
through in the last six years in prison
that I've gone through in my own
personal life were pretty extraordinary
and to be able to incorporate them was
necessary when you guys went back to the
network I mean you knew part of this is
that you'd have to figure out a way to
get him back in the pokey right I mean
that was part of the pitch that wasn't
my idea
no I figured that we would have to be
true to the show's DNA but once Paul
shirring signed on to spearhead these
nine episodes I thought well great
because he got the whole thing started
and he has a very contemporary topical
edgy point of view and I wanted the show
to be both this is what you've loved all
along but also something radical and
different and new and it is those things
all right next question hi they're just
the Morales Oh my question is for the
Schofield brothers as you guys just
mentioned you guys were on the flash
together so why can't do we can we
expect any characteristics from Captain
codeine heatwave on Prison Break maybe a
musical I don't know all right like it I
think we're moving on next question
hello my name is Robin I'm from San Jose
and I love Prison Break I still do but
when it was on before I'm so excited for
the new season and my question is for
all the actors um you guys have done a
lot of great work since the last
iteration of Prison Break and my
question is
how do you think your prison-break
characters would fare on other TV shows
you've been on since well I'm kind of
playing one on at the moment um
McCrory is kind of similar to there are
similarities with Nick and Lincoln
I think mix just funnier it'd be
interesting to say buzz them go
head-to-head in a fight I don't know who
would win but um yeah Wentworth or Terra
no please oh sure I think would be neat
to see Michael Scofield on the flash or
legends of tomorrow um he has has always
had a comic book facet a superhero facet
he can endure what the next person
cannot um I don't think he and snart
would get along necessarily because
snart doesn't forget along um it's
interesting idea
I feel like Sara Tancredi in the zombie
apocalypse might not last particularly
long I'm not judging
I don't think that's like really her
wheelhouse um I think she'd do pretty
well on colony I think she'd probably
joined the resistance and she and Katie
would burn down the block I am very
happy to report that t-bag will only be
on Prison Break and no other show so I
never have my next question this is a
question for Welker um do you like
acting on the flash more or the
prison-break more oh that's an excellent
question
excellent question uh I have a lot of
love and appreciation for Michael
Scofield on Prison Break but Captain
Cold is probably my favorite character
to play he's just he's just a good time
he gets to come in do his thing and then
and then scram next question my question
is for Robert plays teabag your
character was very complex you know he
had the good side and the serial-killer
side I'm wondering in the new season
will we see any of that serial killer
side i-i-i I don't want to spoil it I
don't want to kind of want to give it
away too much but I do want to say that
you will see some changes in the
character and you're gonna see this guy
struggling to not be that old guy that
he was before this thing that I did
before you know you won't you'll see him
resisting that a lot
you